Today we are learning English with
Disney’s classic animation Hercules!
If you are interested in Greek mythology
as well as in inspiring adventures,
let’s embark on this epic journey together!
In case you are new here, the scenes
we’ve chosen have NO spoilers.
You’ll watch two scenes from the
movie, learn the vocabulary
and then have the chance to watch it
again without the subtitles.
And, if you want to keep learning with
the best Disney movies and TV series
so you can finally watch them without getting lost,
without missing the jokes, and without subtitles,
just click on the subscribe button
and bell down below.
That’s what Diana did and she has
seen a massive improvement
not only in her pronunciation but
also her vocabulary!
Speaking of success, if you want to
become a successful English learner,
I highly recommend our FwF course! You’ll
have fun learning lots of native vocabulary,
expressions and pronunciation
with the first 2 seasons of Friends.
You’ll receive PDF power lessons
every week and gain access
to our Fluency Circle global community so
that you’re never alone on your journey!
The best part is you can try it for
free with our 3 part masterclass!
Just click up here or in the link
down in the description box below
I will send it straight to your email.
To learn more about how natives
cut and link words together,
make sure you check out this lesson
that Ethan made on our other channel.
You can click up here or the link down in the
description box below to watch that next.